hi I'm vinegar while I'm a professor of
development economics and environment at
the University of Manchester and also
until recently the director of the
institute of economic growth in delhi i
just finished participating in an
exciting and very relevant panel on food
for ha football it's a panel which looks
as issues of food production and food
security and we looked I've in
particular but all of us I think agreed
that we need to focus on small farmer
production in the smallholders because
such a large proportion eighty percent
of India's farmers are smallholders many
of them are also women and so we need to
not only increase infrastructure but we
also need to look at the axis of
smallholders and them in farmers to that
infrastructure we need to focus on
constraints they face in terms of access
to land to credit to water to new
technology extension and to marketing
I've also feel that it's very important
to look at aggregation because if you're
very small you don't take advantage of
economies of scale so aggregation
requires cooperation and although
there's quite a lot of talk about
cooperation marketing and that's
certainly very important we also need to
move beyond that to other aspects of the
value chain for instance it's extremely
important to look at crop planning and
access to inputs of small farmers and
perhaps we can be even more innovative
and see whether it's possible for small
farmers to come together to pull their
land and farm as groups and those would
enable them to get the advantages that
middle level farmers have there are some
interesting ideas VI was chairing the
12th plan working group on disadvantaged
farmers and one of the ideas we put a
cross was the idea of a land bank which
is at the village level if everybody who
needed who wanted who had
and to lease out could put it into the
bank and get returns from that in
everybody who wanted to lease inland
could come to the bank and Lee sin and
this would protect the lessor and lessee
and reduce the transaction costs this
should be open particularly to small
farmers rather than to the corporate
sectors one final point I think we
discussed it a bit but perhaps it needs
much more discussion is that food
security is also about nutritional
security and in that context we need to
look at what happens across households
the inequalities across households but
also what happens within households why
is it that some there is so much
malnutrition still existing in
households which are well off or in
states which have in on average higher
incomes so questions of inequality which
go beyond averages is a key part to are
trying to solve the problem of not just
agriculture production and higher food
production but also its distribution and
therefore food security